so what we have is we have a triangle
the only requirement is that the base
angles here are acute and what we want
to do is we want to somehow either draw
a square so I'm just going to roughly
sketch it out in this case we can see
that you know we have a rectangle that
is slightly wider than it is high so how
can we get a square into this triangle
using just a compass and straightedge
that lies on this base and then touches
the two sides as mathematicians before
we start on actually constructing
something a good question to ask is does
this exist you know how do we know we
can get exactly a square instead of just
a rectangle so what we're going to do is
actually use this idea of rectangles so
as mathematicians sometimes we are
looking for squares but we can't find a
square so we relaxed the restriction and
we start looking for rectangles and then
we hope we can find a rectangle where
the height is equal to the base length
and then we know we have a square so how
can we get wrekt angus well from the
height of this triangle we can just draw
any parallel line to the base and then
drop the perpendiculars and we now get a
rectangle we see that this blue
rectangle is now a lot higher than it is
long the green rectangle was a lot
longer than it is high so we hope
there's a square that lies somewhere in
between this range is you sort of slide
between the turn right so let's actually
draw it out you know what that looks
like so I'm going to draw a graph
actually I'm using a ruler to measure
stuff so this isn't yet a purely
straightedge and compass construction so
we're going to plot the height of the
rectangles as they get lower and lower
so for now I'm going to use my ruler to
draw it out so it is off about 4 units
so over here is going to be about four
units and
at a height of zero the height of the
rectangle is zero so what we have is a
straight line here representing the
height of the rectangle so now that we
have the height of the rectangle we're
going to draw the width of the rectangle
when the height is at the full height
the width of the rectangle is zero so
ever point down here and when a height
is at zero we have the full length of
the base which means we're going to have
a straight line yeah and what happens at
this point of intersection well at this
point of intersection we know that the
height of the rectangle is equals to the
width of the rectangle and so that gives
us a square so we can do a square so we
can do a square and when we had the use
of this ruler to transfer Heights and
lengths around we could find this is the
height at which the square will occur so
if we have a proper construction the
hope is that we can draw a square here
oh yeah so we'll see if we actually can
match them another trick that
mathematicians use is that if they can't
find a square they actually force out a
square so how do I force out a square
here is that it's hard to force a square
in there but I can draw a square down
below so using my compass and
straightedge I can actually draw a
square and we're going to use this to
approximate a compass so over here we
want to draw a square it's going to come
down to here
over here we want to draw a square it's
going to come down to about here and so
this gives us an approximate square and
actually I do not need this ruler
anymore so I'm going to put it away and
just use a straight edge so we're going
to continue this out
and continue this out and now what we
have here is we have a square in this
large triangle so it's not quite the
square that we want in this small
triangle up here but at least it's a
square in a large triangle what can we
say about this small triangle and this
large triangle because this edge moves
down parallel these two triangles are
actually similar so there's a mapping
that brings us from this small triangle
to this large triangle and we can ask
what does the mapping do to this square
because you've got the square now yes so
think about what happens to the base of
this square as we expand a small
triangle to the big triangle and as we
contract it back this base is actually
just going to be a straight line through
to the vertex of the original triangle
likewise over here if we connect the
vertex to this point is how this points
will move as we contract the triangle so
now the base of the large square goes
over to this two points and what that
means is that we now have the base of a
smaller square in this triangle up here
we just need to construct the
perpendiculars and this will give us our
square and as I mentioned earlier we can
compare it to this diagram on the right
and we can see that we are reasonably
close to what the calculator answer is
method one where we constructed the two
lines that intersect to each other to
find the height of the square and method
to where we forced a square to get into
this triangle so now we're going to look
at a third way how else can we relax the
restriction of the square you know
instead of forcing all the vertex to
line up perfectly on the edge of the
triangle maybe we could say hey let's
just have
the base of the square touching one side
of the triangle okay we can also
continue drawing more squares and see
what they look like okay
and so this figure of squares they are
touching the side of this triangle we
hope we eventually will get to a square
that does indeed touch this side of a
triangle if we can find such a point we
are done and what we have here is that
we again have our similar triangles so
we started out with this triangle and we
moved the base over we got to this
triangle so what then does that tell us
about this points and the vertex of this
triangle is that this three points will
form a straight line so we could connect
up this three points and see where it
intersects the other side of the
triangle and then from here we know if
we draw the perpendicular and we drop
the parallel line that will give us a
square that's even that's almost simple
of the other one there isn't it simpler
than the other one and you know both of
this use the same idea of similarity
alright so we are back on the first
diagram and remember what we wanted to
do is start off by constructing a square
so I'm going to just quickly measure off
and we say that the vertex of the
triangle and this corner of our now
relaxed square we want it to want to
extend this line and we can see that hey
it does go through this at a point on a
triangular that's pretty amazing so we
have three different methods here and
they all agree on this one point to give
us the square we drop the perpendicular
we drop the parallel line and we form
our square in this triangle wild so it
looks like or any triangle we will have
those three segments intersecting in a
point
well that point turns out to be the
center of mass or our point which also
is known the centroid